c'est non non
[Musique]
grâce à l'abolition de l'anesthésié
obtenus par nos camarades par vos
camarades
après des années de lutte les
travailleurs les plus démunis vont
désormais pouvoir s'opérer eux mêmes
sans risquer de s'endormir pendant le
dépeçage de maple sandrine brouch a je
suis tourneur fraiseur hill 2 a bien
raison madame sandrine brochard va
maintenant réaliser devant vous sur son
visage grotesque la première
intervention d'auto chirurgie esthétique
comment c'est simple regardez bien
grâce à l'abolition de l'anesthésique
qui ouvre travailleurs les portes de
l'auto chirurgie les pauvres aussi ont
droit à la beauté que belle que moi tu
meurs
etonnant non
[Musique]
fait étonnant non